this video is kindly sponsored by keeps
but more on them later on
hey 42 here when i say the word soldier
to you what's the first thing that pops
into your head
tactical armor sniper rifles
hand-to-hand combat
how about
colourful pajamas
if you've ever visited vatican city the
world's smallest country and the home of
god's representative on earth you
probably know where i'm going with this
because the soldiers tasked with
guarding the pope known as the swiss
guard
do so by wearing what is very probably
the most outlandish uniform of any
military force in the entire world but
why exactly is the pope protected by an
elite force of swiss blokes and clown
outfits
i'm glad you asked
now i want to take a brief moment and
talk about hair loss because i've had a
few people close to me start to lose
their hair as early as their 20s and
it's always an upsetting experience
if you're in the same boat then you're
not alone did you know two out of three
guys will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
but the best thing you can do to prevent
hair loss is take the initiative now and
do something about it whilst you've
still got hair left i like keeps because
it makes treatment super easy by
delivering your hair loss medication
every three months directly to your door
so you can say goodbye to awkward doctor
visits and waiting in pharmacy checkout
lines there's a reason that keeps has
more 5 star reviews than any of its
competitors and hundreds of thousands of
men trust them for their hair loss
prevention medication
if you're like me you're probably not
ready to lose your hair just yet but
prevention is key the faster you act the
faster you'll see results and the sooner
you start using keeps the more hair
you'll save
so if you're noticing that you're losing
your hair do something about it for a
limited time go to keeps.com forward
slash 42 or click the link in the
description below to receive 50
off your first order
the swiss guard is one of the most
unique and intriguing military forces in
operation today
for starters it's one of the oldest
standing armies in the world having been
founded more than 500 years ago
it's also one of the smallest with just
135 members
but thanks to the vatican's minuscule
size swiss guardsmen actually make up
about 16
of the nation's total population
that means there's a genuine argument
for vatican city being the most
militarized country on the entire planet
as for why the pope is guarded by a
swiss army in the first place well
whilst us european types like to poke
fun at switzerland for generally staying
out of things in the face of war it
turns out that a few centuries ago
switzerland boasted some of the most
ruthless and efficient warriors alive
as a result swiss mercenaries were
incredibly sought after often being
drafted in to bolster the armies of
other nations across europe and it
wasn't just their skill in battle that
made swiss mercenaries so coveted they
were also renowned for their insane
bravery and unshakable loyalty
traits that made them ideal bodyguards
for world leaders and other vips and as
i'm sure you'll agree no p
is more vi
than the pope
in the early 16th century the stellar
reputation of swiss mercenaries caught
the attention of pope julius ii
even amongst popes julius ii
was kind of a big deal he established
the vatican museums that are still
visited by millions of people today over
500 years later he approved plans to
turn saint peter's basilica into the
largest church in the world a title it's
held ever since and he commissioned some
random painter decorator by the name of
michelangelo to spruce up the ceiling of
the newly completed sistine chapel
whatever that is
men of the stature of pope julius ii
inevitably earned themselves a few
enemies on their rise to the top and so
in 1505 he asked switzerland if they
wouldn't mind lending him 200 of their
finest mercenaries to form his personal
guard
soon enough the men were on their way
it's quite a long march from switzerland
to central italy but apparently all
roads lead to rome so at least there was
no chance of getting lost still it took
a good four months for this elite
fighting force to complete the journey
the swiss soldiers arrived on the 22nd
of january 1506
and
they've been there
pretty much ever since
as for why they wear uniforms that look
like they were designed by a
five-year-old on acid the reason is
actually pretty simple the bright colour
scheme was chosen to reflect the house
colours of two of italy's most important
noble families at the time the dela
reveres and the medicis both of whom had
supplied the catholic church with
several popes over the years and whilst
the various archaic elements of the
uniforms may look pretty ridiculous to
the modern eye it was fairly standard
stuff during the renaissance when they
were first worn
i'm no tom ford but i think it's safe to
say 500 years is enough to make even the
most conservative of fashion choices
look a little outdated the swiss guard
uniform holds the distinction of being
the heaviest military uniform currently
in use weighing in at over three and a
half kilograms and it's so eye-catching
that swiss guards stationed near roads
aren't allowed to wear them for fear of
distracting motorists and causing
traffic accidents
each uniform is made up of 154
individual pieces and every set is
tailor-made for the soldier who wears it
a process that takes around 32 hours
across three individual fittings
the weapons of the swiss guard are
similarly old school mostly consisting
of hal birds and a variety of swords
you may have heard that michelangelo was
responsible for the uniform's original
design
but i'm afraid that's a myth spread in
part by american author dan brown
although coincidentally parts of the
modern version of the uniform which was
redesigned in 1914 were based on
frescoes painted by michelangelo's
renaissance rival and fellow ninja
turtle raphael
by now you might be thinking the swiss
guard with their silly outfits and
medieval weapons
are a bit of a joke a mock military
force that's more for show than anything
else
but before you have any ideas about
getting some mates together to initiate
a hostile takeover of vatican city and
declare yourself pope
i should point out that underneath the
mental uniforms swiss guardsmen are
actually elite soldiers who undergo
rigorous special training the uniforms
i've been talking about so far are only
used for ceremonial purposes and to
impress the tourists
when the swiss guard are engaged in more
traditional soldiering and other
protection duties they wear modern
uniforms and swap the medieval weaponry
for high-tech firearms and pepper spray
in short you really don't want to mess
with them
over the centuries the swiss guard have
had a fair few chances to demonstrate
just how tough they are
but probably their most famous military
engagement came just a couple of decades
after they were founded
in 1527 20 000 soldiers belonging to
holy roman emperor charles v
stormed the city of rome
looting and pillaging as they went
charles v was a member of the house of
habsburg by the way long-term viewers of
the channel will be pleased to hear he
did indeed have a truly gargantuan chin
i should probably mention that whilst
the rampaging soldiers were part of
charles the fifth's army
they weren't actually sacking rome on
his orders the men had gone rogue after
payment of their salaries was delayed
union disputes have gotten a lot less
dramatic in the past 500 years haven't
they
anyway rome's garrison numbered around
5000 men at the time
meaning the city's defenders were
outnumbered four to one
luckily they had an ace of their
collective slave
elite swiss guardsmen
as charles the fifth soldier swept
through the city slaughtering and
stealing left right and center the swiss
guard prepared to defend the supreme
pontiff clement
vii the resulting battle has since
become known as the stand of the swiss
guard
of the 189 guardsmen in the pope's
employ at the time 147
held
first the teutonic cemetery and then the
steps of saint peter's basilica against
thousands of attackers
they signed up for the swiss guard
knowing they might have to give their
lives to protect the pope
and that time had come
[Applause]
sure enough by the end of the day all
147 guardsmen were dead but that didn't
mean the stand of the swiss guard had
ended in failure
you see the men had known full well
there was no chance of victory there
were simply too many enemies and sheer
weight of numbers would eventually tell
but the guards weren't fighting to win
they gave their lives to buy time
because whilst they fought to the death
outside the basilica the remaining 42
guardsmen yes 42 led the pope to an 800
meter long secret passageway known as
pasito de borgio that links vatican city
to the castel san angelo to this day
there clements vii successfully made his
escape
he remained pope until his death seven
years later
if all of this sounds interesting to you
and you're keen to try and join this
elite band of colorfully clad badasses
i'm afraid you're out of luck or at
least you probably are because the
requirements to join the swiss guard are
incredibly strict for starters the name
isn't just for show you literally do
have to be swiss to join which rules out
99.99 of the world's population right
off the bat
not that simply being swiss is enough of
course
not by a long shot those wanting to join
the swiss guard need first to have
completed basic training with the swiss
army they also need to be male and
between the ages of 19 and 30 at least
174 centimeters tall and unmarried
oh and they have to be catholic
obviously
if you do happen to be swiss tall young
unmarried catholic and in possession of
one standard issue penis
then congratulations you've won the
swiss guard lottery unfortunately i'm
afraid this particular lottery doesn't
pay very well
the salary for a swiss guard is 1300
euro per month tax-free that's about 400
euro below the national post tax average
salary in italy and almost three and a
half thousand euro lower than the
national average in switzerland
a country that's regularly ranked in the
top three nations worldwide for the
average post-tax income on the plus side
the swiss guard does have one of the
best retirement plans
in the entire world
you'll almost certainly get to go to
heaven
so maybe it isn't such a bad career
choice after all
thanks for watching